oh well first of all David Neil said
that you are awesome and why is that
because everything is awesome so welcome
to an introduction to machine learning
using Lego and in the next hour we will
go through some very basic machine
learning theory and see how we can apply
that to make a lego car steer by itself
but before that's a bit about me Who am
I
my name is Sarah and I work here in Oslo
as a consultant at Patera
and even though I live and and work here
in in Oslo I am actually from Denmark
and you may know that Denmark is the
world capital of Lego so even from a
very young age I was building Lego I
Christmas I just wanted Lego nothing
else and every time I have visitors I
just play with their Lego and every time
that Lego they makes a new LEGO Technic
set I go out buy it and I build it but I
guess you are not here just to see old
photos of me building Lego but I guess
most of you have been playing with their
Lego at some point and I guess that many
of you have also been working with Lego
Mindstorms so let's go back to 1998 in
1998 the first Lego Mindstorms was
released this one it's called
Lego Mindstorms RCX and I see that some
of you are old enough to have been there
playing with there this what I most
certainly am old enough so when this was
the released I spent all my money on
this set so this is actually my first
Lego Mindstorm set and as you probably
also know Lego lasts forever but one
thing that doesn't last forever
that's Windows XP and unfortunately you
need Windows XP to to program this old
RCX robot so later on this talk I will
use a newer edition of Lego Mindstorms
the main objective for today is to make
a Lego Castilla by itself and I guess if
you have been playing with the Lego
Mindstorms you probably already have
been have made a car which could steer
by itself you probably made a car that
looked a bit like this it had tracks and
a light sensor then you can use a fairly
simple algorithm that says when the
light sensor sees black then drive left
if not then drive right and we see here
that it is actually working it in a bit
of a wiggly motion but again it's
working but this is not a real car as
cool as it would be to have four tracks
on our cars at home that's not really
the case a real car has set wheels and
has have a more normal steering so let's
try and build another robot that looks
more like a car a Lego car which has
wheels and a more normal steering can we
change the algorithm just a bit and
still follow a black line well if we
start on the right side off of the black
tape here and then start driving let me
steer left wait for a bit
steer right wait for bit steer left and
so on it is possible to follow the line
but there the motion is even more weakly
than the one we saw before
so this might be a bit too simple if we
want a little car to steer by itself
yeah but then on the right someone said
Tesla and that's right this is a this is
a promotion video from Tesla and Tesla
when it comes to driving they can do
almost anything they can follow the road
they can keep a certain distance to the
car in front of it they can layer take
turns a Tesla can also park itself and
this might be a bit too advanced what we
can do in just one hour so let's do
something in between these two their
problems so let us define the problem we
want to solve as we want a lego car with
normal steering which can follow a black
line we want to use machine learning and
see what is the most simple machine
learning algorithm that we can use and
still solve this problem so let's skip
Lego for a bit and just focus on machine
learning we will now go through some
very basic machine learning and this is
an introduction and we do not have a lot
of time so again it's just the very
basic theory that we will they look at
machine learning can solve many
different problems and there are many
different algorithms but throughout this
talk I will just be talking about
supervised learning and here we have a
definition of supervised learning and
let me just read it supervised learning
is the machine learning task of learning
a customer learning a function that
map's an input to an output based on
example input-output pairs maybe this
makes sense to you maybe it doesn't so
let's look at an example
example if we want a machine learning
model which can map an image of an
animal to what kind of animal it is then
we just saw that we need some
input-output pairs we can also say that
we need some features and we need some
labels and here we have let's see if
this is working we have an input that's
the image of the tiger and we have the
wanted output what we want the model to
predict that's the tiger here and we
need a lot of sample data so let's
collect a lot of sample data and put it
into a magic algorithm a lot a lot a lot
of data then this algorithm it
calculates for a while and outcomes are
trained machine learning model and let's
see what we can use this model for we
can use this model too if we give it an
input in this case an input of a cats
apparently it was very easy to find a an
image of a cat online then we want the
model to predict what kind of animal is
on this picture we could train this
model ourself but it would take a lot of
time and we need a lot of data to do so
so maybe we could just use a pre trained
model let's try and do that for example
we can use Google cloud vision API so
what result do we get if we take this
image of this cat put it into a Google
cloud mission API what what is the
result and now I don't know if it is the
file name which they gave it away but
apparently Google can tell that this is
actually a cat and Google is pretty
smart about this so it can it also gives
us a lot of other labels
that this is a mammal it has whiskers
and and so on what we just saw here was
an example of classification and
classification takes an input some
features and maps it to a limited set of
categories for example it maps to cat
dog horse and so on we also have
regression and regression Tex and input
some features and maps it to a
continuous value so let's look at
regression for example if we want to
predict house prices in Oslo this is an
example of a regression problem because
a house price that is a continuous value
ranging for example from 2 million
eating crow know to many a know eating
crow now this model it needs some
features and a good feature is a feature
that tells something about the tell
something about a house price so for
example here the South the size of a
house it tells something about there the
price of a house also the number of
rooms well if there are more rooms
there's probably the house becomes more
expensive and the same with the number
of floors so these three features they
are probably good features in there in
this example hopefully now the
definition makes a bit more sense and we
can even rewrite it a bit so it gets
supervised learning is the machine
learning task of learning a function
that map's a set of features to an
output based on labeled training data ok
we now more or less know what how a
model works that we can take an input
and then the model will give source a
prediction an output but how do we come
up with this model we're going to take a
look at that now to make things a bit
easier force and two in a couple of
minutes visualize the development of a
model a bit better I'm going to reduce
the number of features to just one so we
just look at the house size and call
this feature X the next thing we need is
some sample data and we have that here
on the x-axis we have the feature the
house size and on the y-axis we have the
labels we have the health price did
let's say something wrong on the x-axis
we have the house size in square meters
and on the y-axis we have the house
price the next thing we need to come up
with is this function that definition
talked about a function that can map all
of our sample data in a good way and
this is called a hypothesis and let's
just try and come up with a function it
looks like there's a somewhat linear
trend in this data so we come up with a
linear function and it's this a function
that the maps our sample data in a good
way
well maybe yes but maybe it looks like
we have a bit more data below the
function but it's okay but what about
this one is it better maybe we need to
somehow tell which of these ones are
best so what we're going to do we are
going to introduce some feature weights
we're going to introduce
theta 0 and theta 1 and our goal now is
to find values for these 2 theta and to
do this first we need some notation
where m is the number of training
examples and X I Y I is a specific
training example next thing we are going
to define is the cost of a single
training example and the next thing we
define the cost function and again I'm
not going into details of why the cost
function is like this but a very
important thing to to know here is that
the cost function if we minimize the
value of the cost function we will get
the optimal values of theta 0 and theta
1 so that's our next objective it is to
minimize this cost function but before
we do so let's again take a look at this
linear hypothesis with just a single
feature because we will see later on
that to make a lego car drive by itself
we need more than just one feature so
let's expand it a bit two more features
so now we don't just have X we have
features x1 x2 x3 and so on and for each
feature we also have a feature weight
theta so now we also have XJ a specific
feature and theta J a specific feature
weight
okay again remember our objective right
now it is to minimize the cost function
and to do this we use an algorithm
called gradient descent and again I'm
not going into details why the algorithm
is like this but the main thing to check
with you here is that we repeat
something a number of times and what we
repeat is that in each iteration we get
a value for each feature weight
each theta that is just a small bit
better than in the last iteration and we
repeat this a number of times and how
many times are we going to repeat this
well that depends on the problem and it
depends on weight we're here we have it
the feature weight alpha we are coming
back to this and we will see how many
times do we need to repeat this and how
to find a good value for alpha okay
that's enough for with their math for
now so let's go back to Lego because our
main objective as I have said a couple
of times is to make a lego car steer by
itself
and to do so we of course need a lego
car so I made a fairly simple car here
it contains two motors one motor for
driving and one motor for steering the
front wheels in addition it also has a
sensor which can tell when the steering
is in the most left or most right
position so now we have machine learning
we have Lego what mode we need for a fun
night we need a nap of course
everybody needs a nap so I created an
app which can do three different things
it can collect the data
it can train the model with gradient
descents and lastly it can test-drive
the trained model so the first thing
collect the data how do we collect data
let's take a step back and more in
general how do one collect data for a
machine learning problem well if you
have an Android phone for example then
chances are that you are helping Google
right now collecting data for their
machine learning algorithm algorithms
it's yeah you're probably probably doing
that and if we take a step back to when
we looked at this Google vision API
where Google can tell us what is on a
picture actually actually you can also
help Google collect assemble data for
for this you can for example go to
crowdsource google.com I did that I
registered and now if I go into this
site Google Google gives me questions
they gave me this question are there any
buses in this picture and I can select
no oh yes and I of course selected yes
because there is actually a boss in this
picture and what I was thinking here is
that well Google knows everything
Google of course knows that there is a
boss in this picture so is this a trick
question or but when I click yes I got
another question well actually I got the
same question but with another another
picture
are there any bosses in this picture so
apparently Google doesn't really know if
there is boss in this picture what they
do now I said no there isn't
so there are many different ways of
collecting your data for our problem how
are we going to collect data well first
we need to decide which data are we
going to collect
we need to decide which features to use
so we have a Lego car it is going to
drive on top of a black line the black
line is that a feature well yes it is
what about the rest of the road in front
of the Lego car is that a feature oh yes
most certainly most certainly so the
road in front of the Lego car not so
feature and how are we going to see the
road in front of of the car we are
placing a smartphone in front of it with
a camera when I click collect the data
in in the app we get to this page where
here we see the camera view everything
the camera sees in front of the Lego car
and can we then use all of this camera
view as a feature well we could probably
do that and now I say a feature but here
we actually have multiple features we
could say that each single picture pixel
in this picture is a feature and we
could most certainly do with that but
this gradient descent that we took a
look at before I have implemented that
in a very simple way in there in the app
and I have not used any framework like a
Google tensorflow or something like that
so actually in that algorithm it not is
not in that fast and the more features
we have it just takes longer to compute
so I'm guessing that using old picture
pixels here will take too much time and
also we want this to be as simple as
possible so instead let's see if we can
use just a single row of pixels and see
if that's enough to get the Lego car to
stare by itself so we use this red line
here that's our all the pixels in that
line that is our features
and a picture we have here below that's
actually the same it's just that single
pixel roll stretched in the vertical
direction one last thing we need because
now we have defined our features we also
know if you need to know what is our
label what is the output that we want to
predict we want to predict the steering
so let us just predict the steering
angle of the front wheels of the lego
car now we have to find our features we
have to find the label but how are we
actually going to collect this data
could we just take the Lego car put it
on top of the black line and then angle
the steering a bit take a picture and
manually say well I think it's 10
degrees or I don't think that would day
would work so instead we are going to
collect data steering the Lego car
manually with a controller let's see how
what what it looks like
I click collect data and I give the
model a name create the model and every
time we do something with this Lego car
it needs to initialize the steering so
it goes all the way to right all the way
to left all the way to right and sensors
the steering just yeah so we know that
we're there in the center position is
and now yep just one note the driving
motor I have disconnected that because
otherwise yeah the car will just
continue straight on but you see here
how the steering is actually working
when I steer the controller the car is
steering
yeah next thing we need is a training
course and too much happiness of the
rest of the houses residents I've
removed all the furniture from the
kitchen and decorated the floor with
black tape so now we have a training
course let's collect some data I can
click collect data and I give the model
a name the steering is initialized and
wait for a bit and there we have it I
turn on the camera flash and I start
collecting data and what we see here
well seen it before we have the camera
view we have this stretched pixel line
the pixels that we are actually
collecting and here we have a red
vertical line and that red vertical line
that is the steering angle that I am
actually steering with the controller
and you see how that there's a bit of
lag time it takes a bit of what can say
it doesn't update that fast the bottom
picture but every time it updates we
collect sample data so yeah we collect
and we need to collect a lot of data so
round and round round I go now we
collect a lot of data mainly going left
but we also want the car to be able to
drive right and
we can't make it go right if we have
haven't got enough data going right so I
turn the car 180 degrees and guess what
happens
yep continue and I collect more data
yeah that was a fun afternoon what do we
actually collect well we collect that
this is what I actually collected and
here we have on the left the labels the
steering angle ranging from not actually
an angle but the angle in percent from 0
to 100 and on right here we have all the
features who had the first feature that
missed a pixel value of the first pixel
pixel value of the next pixel and and so
on so we have one row of way of pixels
yep done so now we have data the next
wing thing we're going to do we want to
train the model so let's take a step
back
remember this linear hypothesis we can
rewrite it just a bit so it maybe makes
a bit more sense that we have a function
that's the steering angle is equal to
theta 0 plus theta 1 multiply it with
the first pixel value plus and so on and
again remember these theta values they
are our feature weights and when we are
training the model we are actually just
finding the best values for these theta
values and remember how we do that we do
that with gradient descents where we
repeat a number of times and algorithm
and also we must find a good value for
this learning rate okay so let's do all
that
yes the learning rate I have cheated a
bit
I had tested some different learning
rates and I came up with a good one
a good learning rate was one so I said
alpha equals to one and we will see now
gradient descent working and when it's
great in descent working remember that
in each iteration we get slightly better
values for theta and when we get
slightly better values for theta we get
a slightly lower cost and again remember
that our objective right now is actually
to minimize the cost so what I have done
on the right in in the app is to plot
the cost in each iteration and we see
here that in 500 iterations with a
learning rate of 1 we see that gradient
descent is working because the cost is
getting lower in each iteration we also
see that the learning rate is a good
learning learning rate because we see
that the cost is converting and when the
cost is converting it is has been
minimized so now we actually have a
trained model we have found the best
possible values of all these theta
values but again I said that I cheated a
bit I've we just used a learning rate of
1 but what if we pick a smaller learning
rate what will that look like
let's see now we pick a learning rate of
0.001 and again let's take five hundred
iterations the same as before we will
now see that gradient descent is working
the cost is getting lower so yep it is
working but we also see that in five
hundred iterations
we do not see see the cost converting so
again it's working but gradient descent
is just working slowly and that's why a
learning rate of 1 in this case it's
better but because we do not have a lot
of training later right now but imagine
that I walked around in my kitchen for
much longer period then we would have
more training data and gradient descent
would be slower so yep we also that we
always want a good learning rate now
some of you are probably thinking well
why don't we just fake an even bigger
learning rate it looks like that when we
have a big run and rate everything goes
faster and that's awesome
not always so let's now pick a bigger
learning model let's running rate again
500 sir Asians and learning rate of 2.5
now we see that gradient descent is not
working because in each iteration
the cost is not becoming lower in some
iteration Sidious but it needs to get
low in in in all iterations so the cost
is fluctuating and over time it is
increasing so this is not a good
learning rate we need a smaller learning
rate and just for the fun of it let's
try a very big learning rate let's use a
learning rate of 100 and again 500
iterations now we get an error and we
get an error because in the first
iteration the cost gets so big that it
cannot be contained in a 32-bit float
and yeah the app simply generates an
error but now
we have a model a trained machine
learning model let's do a test drive and
yes it was my time to take care of the
baby so yeah we initialized the steering
again
turn on the camera flash and we start
driving and what we see here before we
had a red line that was the line that I
manually steered the blue line here
that's the predicted steering angle from
the model otherwise there yeah view of
firm this driving page in the app is
more less the same we still have the
camera view in front of the of the car
and this single pixel row our features
stretched well that worked fine they're
not perfect but we now have 25 minutes
left okay but let's continue let's see
let's be the double get off damn it no
went of course if this was a Tesla we
would have crests no and again nope
doesn't work let's continue let's see no
angry baby it doesn't work no okay
what's going on here we have a model
which seems to work sometimes but it's
just not working well enough so let's
examine that
it turns out that we have two different
arrow situations let's look at the first
one first we see here here that the
black line goes left
so we also steer left but what we will
also see is that when the camera just
sees about half of the black line then
the model or the car doesn't know what
to do so you see here that it just
continues straight on and when it
continues straight on it doesn't see the
black line and it doesn't know what to
do so that's a problem why is that well
we have just tried one model we have
tried this linear model it's this the
right model for this problem maybe maybe
not
do we have some bad data do we have
enough data of of the car driving left
maybe maybe not
do we have bad hardware can when I have
been steering can can the camera
actually see all of the road in front of
it maybe maybe not the next arrow
situation again the car is say going
left but then look at the black line
suddenly the black line is not that
black anymore it turns more of a grayish
color let's see it again
yep here it turns gray and when the
black line turns gray the model don't
know what to do hang on that's a problem
same as before
do we have the right model maybe some
bad data have we trained for this
well it actually turns out that the
second problem we can solve that in a
very easy manner we can use a well-known
machine learning technique called the
curtain fall procedure and that's very
easy to implement so let's do that there
it was very easy to implement very fast
this may seem like like a joke but when
working with sensors or cameras
sometimes it's just easier to fix things
on on the hardware side than it is to
fix things on on the software side so
for now quick fix what about the model
do we have the right model for this
let's take a step back and look at the
data we had for house prices in in Oslo
here we chose this linear model and the
straight line we have here the the
function we have here is it's the best
possible function for this sample data
let's come up with another model here we
have added the squared feature the
squared feature X does this model map
the sample data in a better way
well usually when doing machine learning
you would have some test data that is
different from your training data and
you would just test these two models and
see which model is performing best on on
the test set in principle we could do
the same but of course we're dealing
with the Lego so we take a more
practical approach so in a bit we will
just test drive two different models and
see which model
better and just to make everything clear
we have the function we used before the
steering angle is equal to to something
and now we add squared features again
all the squared pixel values we used to
the same training data and I trained
with gradient descents we're not going
to show that again
okay ready for our new test drive now
with a new model again the same training
data as before and we have done gradient
descent we now in its allies the
steering turn the camera flash on and we
drive if you're wondering why I turn the
camera flash on that's just to make the
data a bit better to make the light part
of the picture a bit lighter without
actually doing the black line light oh
yeah we saw that it's working we have a
better model now but just for the sake
of it let's turn the car 180 degrees and
yeah there's a reason why it doesn't go
so fast right now yeah again mini Tesla
crests and let's continue and nope it
looks like we have a better model but
unfortunately we still have problems
yeah and the baby have learned to were
to walk since laughs here okay so now we
have a better model but let's look at
the hardware um the camera I said before
maybe the camera doesn't see all of the
road in front of it
so we can try and change the angle of
the camera just a bit so that we see
this feature line that we use the pixel
line it becomes a bit closer to the
robot and when it comes becomes a bit
closer to the robot we will see that the
black line hopefully will not disappear
out of the picture just as as easy so we
try and change that as well so what have
we done so far
well we have fixed the light conditions
we have come up with a new model and we
have tested the new model and it looks
like it is better we have changed the
hardware just a bit we don't know if
it's better but we have changed it what
about the data let's examine the data
from we collected earlier yes so we will
now see again the data collection we did
earlier but in some parts I will slow
down just a bit so we can see what we
are actually collecting fast fast fast
and here we see it we see again every
time the bottom picture updates that is
when we collect data and we will see
that sometimes we do not see the black
line in the picture and that's a problem
because what
is that we want to do we want to follow
a black line if we cannot see the black
line that's a problem what is the model
going to do one thing we could do is
manually to go through all the data that
we have and remove all the bad data
maybe that would give us a better model
I've not tested that but I think you
would get a better model but this is
also a problem because probably we do
not have enough data going left and
going right yeah okay now we have
mothered modified the car and when we
have modified the car we new need new
data we cannot use the same data anymore
so let's collect new data and also I
will make sure that I'm a bit more
concentrate concentrated concentrated so
that I actually steer the car on top of
the black line and not go too much left
and right so let's collect
[Music]
and we collected in both directions and
if you counted the seconds then yes I
did walk around in circles in my kitchen
for 20 minutes okay now we have a new
model we have a data and behind the
scenes I have done gradient descent so
we have trained the model let us test
drive again again we initialize the
steering all the way left alder way
right and then send supposition
turn on the camera flash and we start
driving fingers crossed
speed it up a bit and we slow it down
here that here we had a problem earlier
it looks better now and one thing that
you can take a note here is that the
predicted steering angle sometimes get
all the way to zero percent all the way
to left and all the way to to the right
100% we did not see that before so it
looks like the car can actually steer
when it's yeah sharp turns to both the
left on to the right but just to make
sure we turn the car 180 degrees and see
if it's working going mostly right again
here we have a problem before also with
the new model so again it looks better
now
yeah it looks like we now have a Lego
car which can steer by itself perfect
but then when I was testing all this I
had a visit from my neighbor and he said
what are you doing and I said well I'm
working with Lego and he replied nope
you're playing with a girl with the Lego
I then explained what I was actually
doing and he said well that is quite
cool but this Lego car of yours isn't it
quite slow can we go to make it go any
faster and I said well maybe I don't
think so but we can test it so let's
speed it up a bit and again I know that
it's not really fast but it is quite a
lot faster than than before and what we
will see here is that it is working
somewhat but we will also see now that
in sharp corners that it becomes a bit
too weakly to the left and to the right
can't really follow the line and now
weekly weekly weekly and no so no it's
not working and why is that well there
are several reasons for this first of
all there is a hardware problem the
steering on this car is simply not fast
enough so it's not it can't change
direction as fast as as the line is
changing another reason is that the
model is trained at a lower slower speed
yeah so the model is probably not
working either also the way that I have
implemented this it is implemented and
you can go and check for yourself later
implemented this in a very simple way
which also makes everything a bit slow
we could have have implemented it in a
better way so that yep maybe it would
work a bit faster and a bit better okay
let's see what have we learned today
well know your data but one thing I want
to say is that many of the things we
have gone through today they seem very
Lego specific but actually many of the
problems here and solutions they can
somehow actually be changed also when
doing normal machine learning so ya know
your data that's very important and in
that also know when you have bad data
and also remove bad data we if we have
bad data for example in our case we have
a pixel row without the black line on it
we cannot use that we have also seen how
to find the best learning rate by
plotting the cost over each iteration
when doing gradient descent another
important thing is to miss your model
performance and in that pick the right
model and again when doing normal
machine learning you would have a test
set where you measured your performance
but in this case we just yeah little
more manual approach by finding out
which model steered better also we can
just make the model make predictions
within the limits of the training data
if we do not have enough data going
sharp left then the model doesn't know
how to go left
can you make any improvements again this
is just improvements to the problem of
following a black a black line we could
most certainly collect more data I am
guessing that if I walked around in my
kitchen
not just for 20 minutes but for several
hours then we would make the car work
even better also we could maybe collect
data in different light conditions maybe
we could even add a light sensor to the
car and use the value from where the
light sensor as a feature maybe that
would make the caste a better in there
in different daylight conditions now we
just used a single pixel row as features
would the caste a better if we used all
of the camera view well maybe maybe it
would again if we were to do this we
would probably not use homemade
implementation of gradient descent you
would probably use Google tensorflow
or something like that maybe you would
even collect data on your on the car on
the smartphone and then do gradient
descent on a normal PC for example it
would probably be a lot faster we could
test other models now where tests have
tested two different models but there
are many different machine learning
models we could for example use and you
will network or something else and along
with the first point more data if we
could collect data faster then we could
collect more data in the same time
okay that was improvements to the
problem that of following a black line
but in the real world cars don't just
follow black lines unfortunately that
will make things a bit easier so maybe
we can come up with something that is
maybe not Tesla but something that is a
bit more realistic and what I was will
say now it's not something that I have
implemented it is just if you for some
reason want to do all of this at home
then after doing that maybe you can I
can I improve on this so this is just
some input on that here we have three
different roads and maybe they are not
real roads but they are more realistic
than just following a black line here we
have that's the rose we have different
wrote surfaces different colors and also
we have different sides of the road for
example maybe the side of the road the
road is not the same if you are driving
on a motorway
compared to a smaller Road and we want
the car to be able to stay on the road
in in all situations how could we
implement this well maybe instead of
instead of doing everything in one
machine learning model you could maybe
do it in several steps first step could
maybe be to find where is the road
ah wrong button here we have the road
and we have converted that here so that
all different roads they are converted
into something that will look the same
for different roads and from that have a
model that finds the steering steering
angle but this is up to you - were to
try that at home
now what's that one more test drive yes
because when working with the machine
learning then we cannot test a model on
the same data that we trained the model
and in our case it's actually a bit
wrong to change - to test the model on
the same training course that we where
we collected the training data so now I
have made an even bigger course going
all the way to the living room and you
will see here that it is actually
working also on another course if you
want to do with this at home or just
want to see what I have been been
playing with then the source code for
the app that does everything here that's
available I will also say that right now
it doesn't come with any explanation of
of any sort it's just the port of the
pure source code later this some offer
it will be updated with a bit more
information so it will be easier to to
find out what's actually going going on
but have a look if you are interested
also time is running out but if you have
any questions then I am outside for most
of the day at the h0 Stan thank you very
much
[Applause]